But it's,
it's hard sometimes,
man,
because there are so many people that are just unreasonable and they're not good
at communicating and they're not happy.
They're not happy people and not man.
There's a lot of people out there that are just aren't happy man.
It's,
you know,
and it'd be honest with you,
I didn't realize it until I got to the notoriety that I am now in the space that
I'm in.
Well,
you're in a weird space.
Yeah.
Because you're in the space of defending guns,
you know,
and I'm black.
Yeah.
And I'm relatively young.
There's a lot going on there.
And we were a lawyer and I work well.
They tend to disregard that.
Well,
they should probably pay attention.
it doesn't matter because I have,
I'm doing,
I'm advocating also with certain three letters behind me.
They automatically assume as the devil.
How does it NRA feel about you?
Do you know?
I mean,
do you have conversations with them?
Are they saying good job or they,
are they pleased or,
oh,
I mean,
as far as I can tell they arms.
We still have the relationship we have.
It's,
it's very much a very symbiotic relationship,
but it's a weird one right now because it's like,
this is what I hear from the NRA.
I hear Coleen [inaudible] and then I hear Ted Nugent.
Those are the two that I hear.
I,
I gotta be honest,
I'm not,
I'm not the biggest fan of Ted techniques,
rhetoric.
Um,
but I do know where it's coming from.
But then again,
I didn't grow up listening to Ted Nugent.
Yeah.
That's not my demographic.
But at the same time took Nugent.
It's still an individual.
And people felt or understand that like we,
like,
we may be monolithic on that,
on the issue of firearms.
We're not monolithic.
And the way we go about expressing that,
well,
he's right about things.
You know,
just because someone's outrageous doesn't mean they're not right.
Like a,
if you ever seen his,
uh,
the s the debate that he had in a gun store with Piers Morgan.
Yeah,
no,
the funny thing is tattoos.
She's incredibly bright.
It is a smart guy.
He's just crazy.
Hell,
I don't even think he's crazy.
I do.
You can only,
you can only kill so many things for you.
Lose your fucking marbles.
Ted Lives on a fucking ranch in Texas where it's all fenced in.
He's just shooting all animals.
He hunts every day.
He's a psycho.
And I don't,
with all due respect,
I'm a big fan of strangle hold.
So what Ha,
what's,
where's the line of demarcation between becoming courageous,
hunting too much and not hurting enough in terms of becoming,
it's crossing over that line into the sociopath?
Well,
I'm just joking.
By the time it's,
I'm a hunter.
I mean it really depends entirely upon what he's doing with the meat.
And I know he gives it to hunters for the hungry.
I know he gives it to neighbors and friends and there's nothing wrong with that.
Then he asked,
he actually has a,
um,
he has an obligation to be the steward of his land because he has a lot of
exotics and stuff on it.
I'm just totally joking around.
Oh No,
I know.
But when you,
um,
when you listen to his conversation with Piers Morgan,
which Piers Morgan takes that flipping leftwing knee jerk reactionary,
you know Eric guns?
Yeah.
He's a con.
And when he's,
when he's on with Ted,
Ted just knew everything about the actual facts.
When you start running around with statistics of gun violence,
he's like,
do you know how many of those people were bad guys that were shot by cops?
Yeah.
Do you know how many of those people were people that were shot when they're
breaking into people's homes?
Do you know how many of those people were people that were killed in self
defense?
Yeah,
there's a lot.
it's not.
And you know how many of those people,
when you sit and talk about gun violence,
how many other people were suicide?
Uh,
yeah,
there's a lot.
Keep in mind that the recent suicide,
well,
no.
So here's what happened.
So when I started getting really deep into the advocacy component of it,
everyone was screaming,
30,000 people a day die from gun violence.
30,000 people a day.
That's what they were running with.
Right?
And they were scaring all the suburban House moms.
Oh my gosh.
We got to do something about gun control.
We got to do something about guns.
Um,
so I,
I jumped into the pool and I,
I,
I just like something doesn't seem right about that figure right now.
I'm not saying I'm the one who brings what's wrong about it.
It's seem inflated.
It seem to fight it.
I don't know what it was.
It's on a subconscious level or maybe,
or maybe it was me looking for confirmation bias,
right?
Because I felt the way I did about farms.
I'll be honest and say that.
Right?
And so what I did is I kind of researched a little more than I realize.
Holy Shit.
Over 65% of that 30,000 is suicides.
65% real.
He's just Christ.
So what does that like 18,000 people a day?
Shoot themselves,
man.
Something crazy like that.
What did we say at the top of the show?
And people are miserable.
Man.
That's a fucking crazy number though,
man.
That's a Kevin Hart concert.
Yeah,
pretty much altogether.
CanNot everybody blam well,
that's really what it is.
18,000 people that,
that's fucking incredible.
So then it,
but then it begs the question that you brought it before the mental health
aspect.
Yeah.
How much,
how much,
how many lives would we actually save if we took the same energy we applied to
just making guns evil and trying to ban guns and take that energy and put it
towards understanding what it is.
W W why as a society,
we have a society that is so eager to really not want to be here anymore.
Mm.